it's the end of days my friends check
out this story from the Daily Mail 1972
prediction of the collapse of society is
on track to happen by 2040. economic
growth will halt in in a decade food
will become scarce and human population
will decline
KPMG study fines they say MIT used a
world simulation model to learn how a
world would fare from 1972 to 2060. the
model looked at a number of factors such
as population industrial output and
persistent pollution and found a
societal collapse Could Happen by 2040.
the research was criticized at the time
but an accounting firm analysis took
another look at mit's data and found
their Stark prediction was correct the
recent work shows are business as usual
mentality will spark a decline of
economic growth within the next decade
but a total Collapse by 2040. I wonder
if there are powerful uh International
Elites who saw that news in 1972 saw
those stories and then not by a
conspiracy but by a standalone complex
very powerful individuals influenced by
similar things decided to take actions
within their Industries in a certain
direction which led us to today oh like
a self-fulfilling prophecy I yeah I got
one I can go back even further what do
you got Nikola Tesla what did he say
1920s and it's just very quick very
quick technical advances are inevitably
driving us toward the grossest kind of
materialism before long the social
system of bee life will be Universal
bee life bug men bug men
Tesla we've got Cuba and Revolt maybe
it's nothing maybe it's uh one off we
got South Africa there was some audio
that was posted by the guy Phoenix
ammunition guys tweeted this out
retweeted it where it's like audio
recordings where he's like we're we're
lending out a thousand rounds they're
saying they're running out of ammunition
and then and then there's another audio
recording where it's like we're running
out of bullets there's thousands of them
we can't stop them by Nightfall the city
will burn it's all the Africa dude when
you look at these things you see Zoom uh
Jacob Zuma's Son by the way oh yeah yeah
yeah responsibly loot responsibly so his
father was the president it was arrested
right right right they did it
responsibly we've got war with China
potentially we've got Russia China Iran
threatening us over what's happening in
Cuba we had that incident a couple years
ago was that in Venezuela where that
cruise ship was like rammed or something
oh yeah the Venezuelan tried to steal it
you get this MIT report and we're
sitting here talking about Civil War and
thucydides trap and the fourth turning
and now we can add another projector to
that you know humans blowing each other
up is one problem and I don't want to
derail this because this is a good
conversation but what I fear is what
happened in Texas when it froze over and
the wind turbines stopped working the
electric grid shut down the centralized
electric grid failed people started
freezing to death wildfires that burn
people alive because they can't get out
uh asteroid impacts collisions floods
we have a centralized electric grid that
cannot handle these things people
without electricity
I I've never seen that in my life and I
don't want to but that is what that's
what I'm afraid of this this stuff
blowing each other up this has been a
threat since no no 1940 this this 20 40
studies and say we're gonna blow up it's
kind of saying Society is going to
collapse jeez yeah well what is society
um that's why I you know one of the
first things I ever did when I got a
smartphone was I downloaded a survival
guide yeah I did too I have one on my
phone yeah because it's just a smart
thing to do people go camping sometimes
yeah if you have a smartphone get one
I'm like you know I might go camping I
need to learn not know how to start a
fire or you know like watch out for
poison ivy or something but hey in the
event that you get lost in the woods
you're gonna love that you got a little
bit of that battery left you turn the
brightness weight down and start looking
like what do I do how do I find my way
out you know what's really interesting
one of the biggest mistakes people make
when they get lost somewhere is they
leave their car you know why that's the
stupidest thing you can do
yeah when the helicopter's flying over
like there's a car and like a million
reasons that's the worst thing you could
do they go down they find the car and
the person's gone or or double back to
it I mean that would be just stay in the
car
I'm not gonna give you advice I'm gonna
say just take care of yourself be
responsible yeah you look at what
happened in Texas there's things like
that that happen but here's the crazy
part our cities have gotten so big what
happens when the power goes out for a
long enough period of time that order
breaks down yeah I mean you look at what
happened in South Africa with all of the
stores being looted the West is being
looted when order is just when people
are like hey guess what Law's off The
Purge happens well and not only that but
not not it's not just order it's when
made to order right it's when On Demand
right breaks down right it's when I
can't get my Disney plus as I can't get
my streaming I can't get this I can't
get my ubereats I can't get all of these
different things where stuff is just
delivered to me by my gig slaves it's
that when that breaks down and suddenly
I have to I know people it's easy easily
exemplified by the uh Treehouse of
Horror with the Simpsons where it was a
play on The Shining and Homer was uh
trying to you know had no TV so he
became he became murderous and started
rampaging around trying to kill his
family the Simpson family and then
finally there are no TV
and then they're outside and then Homer
is like come sit with me by the warmth
of the TV and he finally has a little TV
and then they're sitting there and the
TV power dies and they're frozen and
then Homer says urge to rise or urge to
kill a rising urge to kill Rising that's
basically what it is you're referring to
the crazy thing about this is it used to
be that if you wanted a cheeseburger you
had to wait for it you had to go buy the
ingredients you had to go make it
yourself then we're in the in the diner
era and then McDonald's is like we're an
invent a way where you can walk up and
get that burger real quick and people
were like whoa now people are so spoiled
they go to a restaurant they wait five
minutes they freak out where's my phone
they're throwing stuff at the counter
yeah if we go back to the era where it's
like you got to wait a month to get
tomatoes because you're growing so this
is this is you know having my um
you know my wife and then her parents
live with us and they're from Eastern
Europe right they don't have that they
don't have that at all because they
don't have it may be some of like the
big cities in in Eastern Europe they
have that but and for there for them
it's hey I I went out in the morning I
bought some fresh stuff and now I'm
gonna cook it I'm gonna spend the day
you know washing it and cooking it and
preparing the dinner and getting it done
and that's that I mean they don't uh you
know I joke about this but they won't
even use the the dishwasher they just
why would I use that I can just wash it
by hand right well to be honest
dishwashers don't work yeah they don't
you end up having to wash it anyway
right right but I mean they won't they
wouldn't even consider to putting it in
the dishwasher right you know and it's
it's really is and sometimes we do have
this kind of culture Clash
um they're not big on air conditioning
uh yeah and they're and they're super
they're just super like they're way more
used to hey if you want to get something
if you want some walnuts if you want
some cucumbers hey go outside here's a
basket go get them right you want some
ham berries go do this that's how you
take care of it that's the future not
the best and the future and you look at
what we have now and it always makes me
kind of reflect back on the way you know
strawberries in winter you know you come
out and say
is this better right is is our way
better it's strawberries in winter it's
better for building brain matter because
like having access to all those
nutrients make us able to be stronger
potentially intelligently but people
have been abusing it I mean I've been
walking around I partially disagree with
the aspartame I think I partially
disagree and I think you're correct
about the availability of nutrients but
people eat random trash yeah that's the
problem abusing the system they're not
taking advantage of it right properly
they're taking a disadvantage with it
they go to McDonald's they buy a
cheeseburger and fries what do they have
for dinner I'll do chicken sandwich and
fries and it's like you're not getting
real vegetables you might get a tomato I
guess but that's that's just a fruit
Tanya is a a father when when he came to
the U.S um we went out I think we forget
where we were we were in like some place
and like the only thing that was open
was fast food and we got some stuff and
he was like I'm not eating this like
this
to him he's like this is not food this
is like plastic yeah mush and then so
when I I go over and visit by the way
and you eat the food there like Farm to
Table isn't like they don't even say
that because it
that's just food right right in Eastern
Europe so you get it and then you start
eating stuff and you realize it doesn't
have this sort of sensationalism kind of
tastes that U.S food would have but it's
richer and you can really taste you can
really taste you know the true nutrients
that are in it you can taste so many
different flavors that you weren't used
to having you say oh this is what meat
is supposed to taste like this is what
vegetables are supposed to it's not just
that it's it's when you're eating
nothing but garbage you you lose well
I'll put a better way when you're really
really hungry everything tastes better
when you're eating healthy and then you
have those garden fresh veggies and
you're eating it you're like it just
tastes so good it's like when you
imagine like chugging a bunch of soda
and then eating a scoop of ice cream and
like the sweet your sweetness overload
you ever have that yeah where's the ice
cream doesn't even taste sweet because
you have too much sugar in your mouth
already yeah that's basically everything
I was reading about sugar addiction and
how the sugar content of our drinks kept
going up for a long period of time
because people with drain drink a soda
with like 10 grams of sugar and then
they would find a soda with 15 a bit oh
this one's better and so the next
company's like make it 17 make it 19
make it 20 25. now it's up to I think
for like a Coke 48 grams of sugar isn't
that the thing where and I and I'm sure
this is more of a more apocryphal than
an actual true story but the idea that
cocoa used to be you know it was used to
actually have cocaine in it right so
that was a really good at the name so um
I think that's true you know no no no no
no no no no no that's true the the next
part is you know we're basically they
said well once that was
um once that was criminalized they had
to find something else that was just as
addictive to put in their sodas so they
found sugar well they found caffeine
caffeine has has a very very similar
effect on the human body to cocaine oh
wow
your energy boost yeah oh yeah well I
mean caffeine causes Euphoria it's it's
it like it stimulates the brain in a
very very similar way there actually is
and I think we talked about this on on
one of the last times I was here but
um that you could actually talk you
could actually trace the enlightenment
to the introduction of coffee in Europe
psychoactive stimulants and that's why
people are suddenly right and then prior
to that right if you look at any like
medieval literature or any medieval just
source of the OAC people always they're
going to the end they're drinking Mead
they're drinking that's like people are
kind of buzzed all the time like the
water you know healthy water or
drinkable water was not of readily
available in the Middle Ages and so if
you want something you want you want it
fermented you want something that's been
processed so you are going to be
drinking alcohol more so there's this
idea that people just in the Middle Ages
were just generally kind of buzzed did
you it was it was it was safe for over
to drain you know right did uh did you
know that coke has coffee yeah they do I
did not I just found this out today
really it was really oh a Coca-Cola can
but it's had coffee on it and I was
confused and I was like I'm gonna try it
it's got Splenda in it so I I cracked it
open I tasted I was like wow it's
actually really good yeah I thought it
was gonna be bad and then I was like I
looked at the I looked at the grocery
Pepsi coffee they had Pepsi Pepsi Pepsi
Kona I looked at the nutrition
information on the Coke and it was like
11 grams of sugar and I was like that's
impossible this is way too sweet and
boom Splenda I don't drink that stuff
you should use Stevia uh Stevia is all
right but I just either drink water or I
drink pure sugar you know cane sugar
whatever splenda's sucralose which is I
don't know sucralose yeah it's a it's a
it's a your body doesn't digest it I'm
not a fan of that stuff I like monkey
fruit we've been doing a lot of them
legit what's that let's blend it was
aspartame that it's sucralose yes
I don't care for any of that stuff
that's equal oh this is that they
originally were contained sucralose it's
also known for using monk fruit Stevia
and allulose yeah monk fruit I hear is
all right equal is aspartame and then
sweet and low is saccharin I don't care
for any of that stuff you know we have a
bunch of sodas from this company called
Route 66 Route 66 I just ordered from
it's like a Chicago Company pure cane
sugar
I don't I don't want to have too much of
that anyway but if we're gonna have some
pure cane we do have these Japanese
sodas that are really fun look at the
marble and you like pop it in yeah and
that's fructose glucose syrup which
probably just means high fructose corn
syrup so and we got a bunch of sodas
with that high fructose corn sauce
what's the new stuff uh something
fructose there's a new kind of fructose
that's out that's the other thing by the
way with Tanya she she anything that's
like sodas anything carbonated all that
she just doesn't want any of it water
it's great just amazing she's like I
want she drinks water and if she wants a
little bit of a pick-me-up she'll go for
a green tea I went out to uh we got
pizza today and they didn't have water
I was just like I guess I'll have a Coke
wow I don't like Coke at all yeah it's
the Middle Ages stuff going I mean they
could pour me a glass of water but I
don't want to drink some a big
unfiltered well water you know what I
mean I'm big on coconut water this is
the moho we've been getting and this is
like no other coconut water I've ever
had I mean it's just enough sugar it's
ph balanced for your body pH balance I
heard that they used to use uh coconut
uh water as IV fluid yeah like you could
I don't know if it's true yeah sounds
cool though when I was in when I was
living in China um coconut milk I really
got yaader and I um I was like any yeah
um anywhere I could get it uh or and
it's it's big over there it's actually
pretty big I was drinking coconut milk
like crazy there was actually this
Taiwanese brand that I would just got
really into
thanks for checking out this clip from
the timcast IRL podcast if you want to
see the full show come back to this
channel youtube.com
timcastirl Monday through Friday at 8pm
where you can leave comments and Super
Chat and we actually will read your
comments on the show don't forget to
like share subscribe and if you want
exclusive members only content segments
you can't get anywhere else go to
timcast.com become a member and we even
have full bonus episodes thanks for
hanging out and we'll see you all next
time